I can answer that query stupid
performing its processes it's I think
that's why I was always attracted to
farming as a film subject I could made a
lot of films about farming in Vermont
and all sorts of places because there
was this sense of tracking a process
like a physical and aesthetic process
and something incredibly satisfying
about seeing that so whether it was you
know digging carrots out the ground and
knocking them on the side of a backer to
get the soil of them and then you know
submerging them in water and you know
they're looking of cows or you know the
kids on the farm used to thread wine
bottle lids onto a string and then try
sort of tired around the gumboots and
then do gumboot dancing with an sort of
rattle on the on their boots and I was
just always attracted to those sorts of
images are kind of specific my new
detail often people's hands but also
linked to a natural process in this
sense of the light you know up being
outdoors and these filming in these
places where you know there was just
this sense of being human that I think
we are quite alienated from having
always lived in cities and I think I was
sort of fascinated by that kind of rural
Sensibility I probably have lamented
that and I surprised actually in the
writing it's a similar thing in the in
the book you know a lot of the pleasure
I got was describing again he sort of
minut processes and these three men who
have these very hands on relationships
with the President and so the kind of
you know processes of clipping is here
and you're spraying first column neck or
the you know intricate details of you
know making his meals and so suppose
it's a similar kind of interest in in
that but
I do think it's a it's quite a
nihilistic book and so I really admire
writers who can kind of face beauty hit
on because I think it's much much harder
to write beauty well than it is to write
you know kind of depressing and ugliness
well and so I do hope it's something I
can I can learn to do without ever you
know falling into the trap of being
sentimental I suppose that's always the
problem any approaching and beauty
mhm